if there's one thing most Americans
agree on its that politics are
increasingly hostile a new CBS News
battleground tracker poll finds 84
percent of registered voters in
competitive districts think the tone
incivility of politics are getting worse
Republican senator Ben Sasse of Nebraska
believes it's part of a larger problem
in his new book them why we hate each
other and how to heal sass says the loss
of community in America has helped to
widen the political divide he joins us
here in studio 57 thank you good to be
here right wait do you really think we
hate each other there's a lot of it I
think there's some data that shows over
the last 20-30 years we've gone from 14
percent of the public thinking the other
party's evil to 40 percent of the public
thinking the other party's not just
wrong but evil you write healthy you
write about this unprecedented upheaval
that's happening what's causing it is it
systemic so I would say civil war was
really bad but since then this is pretty
terrible and I think it's not politics
are important but it's not like our
politics are really wrestling with
bigger questions than 15 or 20 or 25
years ago
it's that politics is filling a void of
the hollowing out of natural local
traditional tribes people usually
understood that family shared vocation
workplace neighborhood were the core
places where your identity was found you
know they look into politics you've got
some data to back this not just your
opinion mail absolutely yeah the size of
homes yeah so in the last 50 years
average size of a new home in America
has grown 350 percent and yet there's a
lot of data that shows if your house
gets farther and farther from their
neighbors you're less likely to know the
person who lives two doors from you
that's statistically correlated with
being happy a bigger square footage
house actually doesn't really make you
happier we also have less friends Ben
you say that we're living through a
crisis we're literally dying of despair
and we have less friends we're not doing
as much with each other and to each
other
loneliness loneliness you said is the
number one problem really in this guy at
the NIH you got a whole bunch of
researchers and scientists who see
loneliness as the number one public
health crisis in America we've had a
having of friendship in 27 years the
average American in 1990 had 3.2 friends
today one point eight forty percent of
people have either zero or one confidant
that hurt and a lot of them the
confidante is their phone there's no
doubt we're seeing a shift in
social norms we're also seeing a shift
in political norms as well and your
Republican colleague Senator Marco Rubio
said he doesn't think we're gonna be
able to go back to the way things were
the political norms do you agree with
that I think we're headed toward a
deeper darker tribal place for a time
the question is how we I named this book
them because we act like political
differences are sort of core anti
identities for people until you have
things that you're for first you're not
gonna be able to figure out what we're
trying to do together in politics
politics again I think politics are
important but they're not the first
thing they're certainly not the only
thing and I think right now our politics
are suffering because a lot of people
are looking to find a grand meeting
there because we're not reflecting well
on these core under minors of happiness
at home we talked about this yesterday
but to the extent that people have
filled this hole with politics they're
watching it on TV all the time there
could be many more examples of you or
your colleagues reaching out to each
other and saying I'm not going to treat
you like a person who has only the worst
motives I'm not gonna call you evil I'm
not gonna say that your perhaps
genuinely held view is all just some
scheme to keep you in office that more
examples of that while people are
watching might be good well said you
want to come and give us a owned problem
with pride and humility I think we
really do have a problem right now where
the Senate is being swallowed whole by
cable TV news there's a whole bunch of
people who instead of seeing the Senate
as a place that you go to from the
community where your identity is rooted
where your friends are where you're
raising kids next to neighbors and they
differ with you on politics but
increasingly we're segregating our
neighborhoods so you don't actually live
next to people who disagree with you
looks the big picture you say most
people aren't watching this polarizing
TV which surprised me but you say this
because you take on the media too so
when we hear anyone powerful and
response to questions about their
behavior attack the media in general as
opposed to merely pushing back we should
look critically at them and their
behavior who are you talking about
senators yes I mean pretty much
everybody in Washington but maybe the
politicians at the top in Washington are
particularly good at trying to just
demonize there's a lot wrong with the
media and again that's not beating up on
any of the four people in this room this
is about the economic incentives and the
way we consume media right now
it's not very economically profitable
for a media outlet to try to speak to
70% of America that isn't how we consume
anymore in the 1950s 70% of households
were watching I Love Lucy was an
important content yeah but it was shared
yet in the last 15 years the
most-watched programming in America is
Sunday Night Football hit a 14% share
for three weeks in 2014 so right now
there's real economic incentives to try
to just speak to the 1% of the public
that already agrees with you
are your legs listening to you to be
better do better it doesn't seem so we
don't listen all that well in Washington
I'm one of eight people out of 100 in
the Senate who's never been a politician
before so I'm new to this place
but politicians talk more than we listen
we should listen more than we talk and
when I'm home I live in Nebraska I
commute every week when I'm home I find
that the vast majority of people don't
really want politics to be the center of
meaning they wanted to get a bunch of
pragmatic stuff done we need to build a
cyber doctrine for the nuclear age we
need to think about job retraining for
an age of work disruption that's coming
in a faster and faster pace but you
don't want to find good and evil in
politics and too many people in the
cable news tribes and in political
parties think that anti tribes are
enough to sustain them and I think most
Americans differ all right you tweeted
about leaving the Republican Party we're
going to be watching thanks for having
me
why we hate each other and how to heal
it goes on sale tomorrow wherever you
like to buy your books